welcome back to las vegas now there are
different types of people on your
holiday gifting list that means a
variety of gifts that you have to go out
and find from kids to adults it can get
overwhelming so if you need help we have
lifestyle expert samantha vickers here
with some great ideas welcome to the
show thank you so much yeah it's great
to be back and yeah it can be
overwhelming when you're trying to
figure out what to buy for everyone and
you know what first i would say start
with
what type of people are you buying for
are you buying for your kids are you
buying for a family are you buying for
the traveler um and so make a list and
then that'll help you you know get going
with it and i do have something for the
traveler here get started with these
items
i do need some new luggage so go ahead
tell me about it so this is delsi paris
and luggage and they are amazing so
there's lots of great features on here
the hard side inside it's um you can zip
out the lining and clean it but this is
my favorite part pack it up
and then hold it like this i know it's
got a
weight indicator right here if it's over
48.5 pounds this light goes off and you
need to take some stuff out before you
go wow that is so helpful because i
could i have a few friends who every
time we go traveling we have to stop and
let them take stuff over their back yeah
so this way you don't over pack and this
is great yeah i know and this is awesome
so this can be found at belk.com okay
and so wonderful for that for the
traveler in your life perfect now this
you guys are taking notes out there yes
now this is for the whole family this is
actually beyblade speed storm motor
strike battle set and this is really fun
they are these little beyblades and you
can customize them you can take them
apart you spin them off of here and then
you battle together and the point is you
want to like the dome yes yes stadium
and this spins around i mean it's
amazing hasbro has done a great job of
creating a full family immersive toy and
i absolutely love it our family has been
battling all week long oh i love that
because when you look at it you think
all right this is for little kids but
adults would have fun
down to you know my eight-year-old have
been battling all week long and it's
awesome and this is hasbro.com so really
easy to find great for the whole family
for everybody yeah and i see for the
people who have a spiritual awakening
yes okay so this is actually the the
next two are local las vegas companies
and so i wanted to feature them because
you know what sometimes you have people
that have got everything and so this is
wonderful from milan threads and these
are crystals and the whole purpose of
milan threads is they wanted to create
everyday items that you can use that
you're going to get the healing and the
energy of crystals in your home so this
is actually a lamp wow this is a lamp
yes so you can put a light in it it's a
lamp they've got bracelets that you can
you know have for teens tweens in
between this little desk time right here
amazing they have these are so cute they
are phone pop sockets oh my these are so
cute yes with a gem okay and where can
you find those milanthreads.com
okay and we have 30 seconds to tell them
about that okay last but not least is
confection kitchen so this is amazing it
is two teenage sisters and their moms
100 homemade chocolates and when i say
100 they're making the peanut butter too
wow so you can find them on instagram at
confection kitchen beautiful and this
actually goes towards you know
her in school and yes events yes
party platters i mean you can customize
great for like neighbor gifts you know
all those kind of things that is for
where can people find more information
about you and get more help because i
know you guys it's getting it's getting
down to the wire it's time yes everyone
you can always find me at
samanthavickers.com or on social media
at synergize